Wow all right thanks for having me today
my name is a BG today I'm a solutions
engineer Hortonworks how many of you
know who Hortonworks is in this room
alright cool fifty percent alright so
I'll just spend a couple of minutes
explaining who Orton versus right so we
all know what Hadoop is so it's around
2004-2005 timeframe yahoo decided to
build this file system and analytics
framework based on google's paper for
MapReduce and HDFS so they formed a team
of 30 or so engineers to build that
system and our in 2006 you know this
open source a project called Apache
Hadoop which had HDFS and my producers
initial projects and they started
working with Facebook and building a
extensive data warehouse platform now
fast forward to 2011 Yahoo decided to
make this team as a separate company and
that's how Hortonworks was born so we
took original 30 engineers which built
Apache Hadoop from yahoo and created
company called Hortonworks the goal was
to create an enterprise-ready who do we
know there's lots of gaps in Hadoop and
we wanted to make sure that we fill up
all these gaps and make Apache Hadoop
enterprise-ready right and one of the
projects or two of the projects we're
going to talk about is stinger right or
stinger antes specifically so I'm going
to follow the same theme that Elliot had
is to make the interactive queries
better right and we all know hive has
certain gaps today it is great for
querying large amounts of data but it's
not that fast for interactive query or
doing dashboarding type of work so
around six months ago we started working
with facebook to invest more heavily on
high because a primarily all of the
customers were used
Hadoop today are using hive as their
data warehouse or extension to that data
warehouse I'm certainly not saying we're
replacing your data warehouse but
extension to that data warehouse right
and lots of investment lots of code has
been developed around hive and the way
hive ql was built was kind of difficult
originally initially when they started
contributing to it so people have
learned their ways from traditional
sequel into hive grill right so now all
these skill sets are basically formed
around hi of itself so we wanted to take
hive into the next generation hi which
supports interactive wearing
dashboarding visualization so that you
don't have to run a query go get a cup
of coffee and your results will be there
right so they if you need to interact
with the system at a large scale so we
essentially make stinger as an
initiative stinger is not a product
stinger is built on an initiative which
basically means we're going to make high
better by improving multiple projects
right so if you see hive today
underneath the high framework is
MapReduce so essentially when you write
any queries in hive it turns into a
MapReduce job underneath right so that's
one is there any question the second one
is we know hive kill is not completely
sequel compliant right so we want to
make sure that we give deep analytical
functionality right we want to make sure
we have wide variety of windowing
functions and we'll see where we are at
with that right so those are the two
two-pronged approach we're tracking
right so first improve the latency
improve the throughput of hive itself
and then improve the functionality of
sequel because we all know sequel as we
as we learn right so three things that
come with is one is take this map reduce
engine and basically improve it
something else because we know MapReduce
framework is not fast enough for
interactive queering secondly do and as
Google release the paper on it on the on
the Dremel we realize that columnar
format gives us better functionality
we're investing heavily on the or see
file format and a couple of them a
couple of the features and functions are
already released into high of 11 we'll
talk about that and last but not the
least test test is the framework will
eventually replace MapReduce underneath
high right for better functionality and
improve speed okay you so as I said it's
it's an initiative right it's not it's
not a product it's not a singular
product so we would we did is we divide
give it up into three phases so for the
first phase we did two things one is
essentially did the base optimizations
and we release or see file and that has
been released with Apache Hadoop in an
open source world and its high 11 as the
project all right so you can download
high of 11 today from Apache or from
Hortonworks calm and you will get the
base optimizations in memory has joined
as well as the or C file format the
second one is it's kind of ironic right
so the new PMC or the new chair of
Apache is Microsoft technical architect
isn't that funny but that's that's great
because they're contributing very
heavily so one of the core focus he
brought his name is chris douglas he
bought brought was we need to make this
better he wrote half of the sequel ansi
standard so one of the focus he got into
high vis let's make these sequel query
language or make hive ql as good as
sequel query language so a lot of
improvements has gone into the sequel
you know compatible types and windowing
functions as a part of high of 11 and
we're adding more and more features to
it as we go along into this journey the
second phase of this project is
essentially the hive query server which
is backed by taste test in Hindi or in
Indian language means fast nothing else
right so what we're doing is essentially
replacing the MapReduce framework and
taking it out and putting
has underneath it so it the downside to
ha at the mapreduce is essentially it
has startup costs for your JVMs as well
as the cleanup costs so there's always a
an expense of your query to start and
then wait for the execution and then
basically clean up so that will go away
because there will be a pre-warm
containers and i'll give you an ability
to do low latency queries you submitted
a job it's ready to go and you'll
function obviously query planner
improvements are ongoing so a couple of
things that you know will see in the
next few slides as how MapReduce work
right and how query planner is trying to
you know improve the data structure
improve the MapReduce jobs underneath
today and then how it will function with
DES vector query engine it will be with
buffer cashing it will be available end
of the year time frame give or take so
that will improve the whole Apache hive
itself as close as to interact your
query engine now that does not mean this
is a replacement for MVP right so the
the far far end goal for this is adding
what NPP does today or traditional
stores like add business rules right
today we don't have business rule more
security structure around that right so
that that's going to come way later
after these phases so that's that's one
of the things that we're also working on
putting into roadmap and essentially if
you look at apache zeros or if you
follow those you will see that a lot of
work is going on a lot of people are
thinking about what they can what they
can take from the traditional edw system
and make high better right so we are
essentially doubling down on hive
because a the file formats or the data
sits into hive or sits on to HDFS
represented by hive can be accessed by
other tools into Hadoop so it makes
ecosystem better it makes the access of
data from other systems better rather
than creating a net new format right and
there there's other projects going on
that will help it improve further
you I'll just keep it down so where we
are at today so as of last month 511 was
released right hiya Levin includes one
key feature is analytical function so
it's not ank it's actually rank sorry I
it's it's a typo in there so I I just
developed a new function in c equal
right Hank so note its rank we had lead
lag first value last value and aggregate
over functions are now available as a
part of hive 11 right there are certain
improvements such as broadcast join and
SMB joints that are available as well as
a lot of a lot of new features for
partitioning rights if you do
partitioning today with virtual columns
you will see significant improvement
with high of 11 right with hive 10 if
you do virtual column partitioning it
puts lots of pressure on name node here
we we made it a lot a lot more better in
high of 11 we'll talk about 0 RC file a
little bit later in the slides but as as
Elliott said it's based on Google dremel
projects so it's a columnar format and
it includes a lot more features I have a
next slide or two tezz alpha was
released also so we released has as an
alpha because test requires Hadoop 20
which is still in alpha to Hadoop 20 has
a new resource scheduling function
called yarn and tez will run as a
container within the yarn application as
application of yarn so tez released as
an alpha about a month ago so you can go
ahead go to apache or go to horse calm
and download you'll have to compile it
but you can play with test today so
what's the goal right so today we know
we can do this weekend at ax mining we
can do batch reporting but this part the
dashboard virtual visualization and
parameter is reporting it's really
tricky you can do it but it takes a lot
of time and patience user don't have
patience to change one field and see how
the visualization changes right it still
takes you know a few seconds to just
start the query and just get the data
out so
the goal is to make that interactive an
idea is to have you know make it more
sequel friendly I have all the sequel
functions in the meantime we have also
built in an open-source odbc driver so
you can download it and it has its own
sequel engine small part of sequel
engine built into it so if you have any
visualization tools in front of hive the
conversion of sequel to hive grill is
much better it has improved from from a
visualization tools perspective not
higher percent but it's still there
right so the query the the sequel engine
the driver itself has lot more features
than before so you can go ahead download
that for free as well okay so what we
did in hive 11 right so first the
intelligent optimizer so in memory has
joins are now available we also able to
make certain improvements in as i said
in virtual column partitioning so we can
now ideally scan through a big file and
we look at directory structure if it's
available we can go in and pull the data
fast enough star schema joins and this
was one of the key things because we're
able to do load the dimension tables
into memory and then distribute via
distributed cache so its speed up things
off the sequel query now how fast is
again depends on your query but at least
is much much much faster than where hive
10 was two months ago lower footprint of
fact tables that's one of the things
that I would like to mention because it
was quite an improvement from from the
memory utilization expected task
trackers let's see all right so hints
are very key because what happened was
with hive 10 hints it's really not
optimal so it created lots of MapReduce
pipelines now those requirements of
hints are kind of going away so high of
11 is much better and you don't have to
there's no need for hints it optimizes
better because there are a lot more
zeros that went into high of 11 that
improves the functions that
the need of hands gone away now okay so
this is one of the things that we did
and this is no way means the speed of
the query but if you look at it the
number of steps that MapReduce has to
take that's basically increment
incrementally added changes to it so if
you look at the hive 10 without hands
you can see there lots of multiple
MapReduce job gets us you know multiple
MapReduce stages started here with high
of 11 star schema join without hints we
could do that only into a you know a two
step process of MapReduce so some of the
things if you look at those jurors we
remove the need of ha hint to the
optimizer itself so you'll see with high
of 11 your queries will now run faster
because the number of MapReduce job will
essentially the need of the number of
MapReduce job will be reduced one key
feature for this or actually one key
benefit of this is will come with Ted's
because today what happens is when you
write a MapReduce job the intermediate
output of the task lands on the disk
right and we all know the disk is much
much much slower than memory so the goal
or the the improvement what in test is
essentially take that intermediate
output of the task and keep it in memory
now we're able to do instead of reading
that data from disk again we can read
the data faster in memory itself so
that's the one of the step to go to test
when you go to Hadoop to go and use test
along with hive and Hadoop 20 you'll be
able to see the square is improved
faster today with high of 11 we will
still collapse that output task onto a
disk for now you go forward all right so
we talked about or see file right we
looked at the storage or the data
structure how how the data gets laid out
so you have txt file your RC file your
sequence file and another new format or
C file this is a columnar structure we
are able to get into hive 11
or moving forward into high because it
is much faster it makes better and it's
evolved in Google Dremel format so
Google would release that paper about a
year ago so you know hi sorry Facebook
started working on it along with
hortonworks and we're able to now
produce a or C file format right so it's
a columnar format it has lot more
features one key feature is we're able
to now consolidate the output of the
math task into a single output file so
traditionally with hives 10 without or C
file you see output files or output of
the task will be split into multiple
files now we can put that into a single
file we can apply a block-level
compression based upon data types now I
don't at top of my head which I don't
know what data ties but you'll be able
to apply a block-level compression so
the footprint is smaller as well as the
amount of data needs to be written as
well as read from the disc is smaller
now we also can add bloom filters so a
bloom filter is a data structure which
gives you you know a predictive
predictive filtering should say gives
you an ability that this element is
exists in the data or not right so now
you can add bloom filters in with or see
file so that you can enable quick check
does my data there or not okay so here's
the file layout right so one of the
things that this is a simple stripe
right so if you look at a stripe it's
around 250 megabytes so it's quite large
so you can pack lots of metadata into
our C file as well as the actual raw
data it has index data index data also
contains the min value max value of the
rows and it also contains the row
locations where they are and you have
the stripe footer which essentially
contains the directory location on HDFS
so you can quickly go get the location
of the file it it also
as as I said block level compression so
you can have again it depends on the
data type which are using today but
eventually it will be available for all
data type so 250 megabytes we think in a
stripe is large enough and it's fast
enough to accommodate that right any
questions so far iorc file okay so let's
talk about the second phase of the
project right so what is test so tez is
a replacement I shouldn't say
replacement there will be MapReduce
framework in Hadoop 20 right will be one
portion of it but tez will be a service
that will enable hi to essentially have
a pre warm containers so when you launch
a MapReduce task will be no more
launching oh sorry when you launch a
hive query there will not be any map
reduce tasks it will run into as a tells
service in the back end so here are the
goals right so we want to enable a low
level data processing using this engine
why because we already know that with
high of 11 when there is a large data
set high of 11 you know can function
better right obviously tails will make
it much much better but if you have a
large data set we're talking terabytes
multiple terabytes the processing is
still there but for smaller data set
when you look at smaller data set we
want to have something better and going
beyond MapReduce so that's what has
that's essentially what led to tez
investment we honor enable efficient
pipelining of the job so the query
optimizations as well as the
intermediate output of the jobs will be
the ones that will make this much faster
so we will with has initiative we will
not write the output of intermediate map
task on to the disk so instead of doing
MapReduce then doing MapReduce you can
just do MapReduce reduce right
and obviously it is built on your arm so
it'll be a it's a young it'll be a yarn
application it is scheduled to go ga
around september-october timeframe but
you can still download this today and be
able to test it right we want to make it
so one thing is one thing with test that
we want to make sure the hive and pig
job are no longer the stepchildren right
so today with high one if you have a
hive and pig job they move to the end of
the queue so tomorrow if you're using
some sort of let's say capacity schedule
or it'll be treated as the
performance-oriented job when you use a
test service okay so this is essentially
the pictorial description of what it
looks like right so tez will have a appt
legation master service which will which
will monitor the containers which are
which will be the test containers
essentially it's live JVM it's always on
JVM type of instance running on all the
nodes so the node manager are there will
be an application master for test
service which will monitor and manage
these containers where your job will get
submitted and the data will get
collected from it okay can you go to the
next slide please so if you look at
today so you have this io
synchronization barrier what we call and
this is what we talked about where the
data lands on the disk right so when you
have a simple query like select
something and count and group by a state
what's happening is there multiple map
tasks are going on and output of those
files are landing onto the disk and then
the next stage of the process picking up
that data or intermediate data and
pushing that into this MapReduce next
MapReduce task so if you look at the
test framework we're able to a make the
query better or may
query optimizer better obviously the
foundation of it and we already have
that the second thing is make the i/o
pipelining better because a lot of
people are using mix set of
infrastructure within their Hadoop in
you know environment so that the i/o
pipeline becomes more and more critical
for smaller data sets for larger data
set it may or may not matter but smaller
data set this is a key where if you look
at hive and pig with tez we can keep the
intermediate data in memory and access
it from there can't go back yes which
instances containers they will always be
running so run as a sort of demon yes
now it will consume some sort of memory
right but obviously then the if you look
at today's hardware we can we can
utilize the memory better right when it
was developed if you look at hadoop 10
it was developed for like eight cores
for 24 to 48 gig memory machines so
that's why you will see now all these
functions are added you know said map
redsplit a sequel to now increase the
heap size when you run now those needs
are gone because now people are buying
128 gig machines at the same cause they
used to buy twenty four gig machines so
that is very very minor yes it will
consume some but not to the extent okay
okay so some of the primary results and
you'll be able to test this when you
download tez right so one of the things
we it is with hive so this is hive 11
queries right so that basically improves
the pipelining this is the reason this
basically says it's less because it's
improved data pipeline nothing else so
the optimizer has now better improvement
so that I rather than launching hundreds
of MapReduce task I can pipeline it
better I can do within 10 MapReduce to
ask right yes we test essentially the
major difference is the launch of my
launch of a server
or you know submitting your job to that
pretty warm container now the reason
behind that the launch it we only say
launch here but obviously when you
launch GV and there's always a shutdown
class to it and as a part of MapReduce
job you'll see at the end but that 30
seconds time is now gone or will be gone
with Ted when you implement hive it tez
a create plan so the query planner is
you know essentially now all these
result sets are high of 11 because now
it's available as GA in Apache so all
these baselines we are essentially based
on high of 11 compared to hive 10 it's a
significant improvement because the
query planner in there okay so this is
the this is essentially the you know
describes tez tez is if you look at the
MapReduce task you look at that engine
as a as a service right so you submit a
job to that service you get an output
it's always on but that's why you get a
low latency right and that's that's
basically what tez is going to be test
is going to be a separate instance of
projects or separates instead of
application running on yarn so you'll
have in a node manager managing and the
subsequent services along with it can go
to the next slide please okay so for
this we talked most of this right so
this is essentially one of the things
we're working on is potentially take it
to future memory-based performance
optimizations and it's not like an
in-memory database but ill with the
extent of having more and more memory on
these servers and available we'll be
able to utilize these resources better
right now we have an ability through
tests to do that previously with
MapReduce we didn't what test will be
able to
premium on this container maybe you know
do some sort of caching mechanism with
tests that will improve that further so
we're still talking you know sub
milliseconds response time we're not
talking microseconds respond time but
that essentially is where we're heading
with the future all these other things
are almost in code complete state for
hive Taz and basically the whole stinger
umbrella framework right so we're
testing now the beta phase of it and
will be released very soon and you will
be able to download that I mean
obviously you can go to patching provide
that but it will is scheduled to release
for GA around September timeframe we
have any more any more slides right how
long do I have for a good on time ok
sure
you can have wonderful I have to so you
can have one
that's above my pay grade but i'll
answer this indifferently right so the
question here is essentially with the
deeper integration with microsoft and
horton worse where we taking tests and
high right will it be replacement for
traditional they are DBMS is that a fair
question right it is that that's a great
question right so that it is actually on
the road map so column story I mean the
question is you know for example getting
columnstore index in hive or making it
almost like an ed w is that the fair
goal right so the answer is potentially
yes right I mean we are trying to get
there as of today the answer is no we're
not there so the first step of the
process is make sure it's equal NC
compliant and Microsoft is contributing
very heavily to that through our
Microsoft partnership essentially two
things happen one microsoft star
microsoft stopped actually developing
their HPC platform all together so there
is no shipping microsoft HPC servers
anymore they actually prepackaged a
data platform or patchy Hadoop
underneath as HD insight so they're
thinking three ways right one we have
this bi lever analytical framework we
own it we have sharepoint we have power
pivot Excel ninety percent of the user
to use that right so let's take
advantage of that second they're working
on a project called hackathon rights
it's one of the things that they
introduced as a part of sequel server 14
a portion of in-memory database right so
if you look at your data access layer
they're working on microseconds response
time milliseconds response time from a
sequel database and Hadoop essentially
for them stands today is a larger
repository extension of sequel server
right now given the framework they're
building on top of it makes the queries
transparent right because working with
Hadoop for a regular user
to an excel is difficult today right
from security from axis from connections
perspective so they're making it fully
integrated solution first piece of that
is making sequel an c compliant second
piece of that build more framework make
it more interactive third is as I said
we're missing a lot of things that
either w has primarily we don't have
business rules right so if you look at
that it's it's it's far down the road
man but eventually it'll get there in my
opinion right and it's not certainly not
only we're contributing it's it's a
democratic investment right so Facebook
is there Microsoft is there so it's
obviously this
that's a great sorry yes sir so tez so
if you look at MapReduce right oh I'm
sorry so his question is what is tez he
is trying to understand in detail what
tez is correct okay so so today if you
look at MapReduce right so MapReduce has
a resource scheduler built into it it's
a job tracker manages it and it
basically distributed to all these task
trackers so what tez is essentially it's
always live JVM engine let's think of
this way you have a Java framework or
Java engine running on every node right
the query optimizer will submit a job to
that particular instance a go do this
for me because of your data locality and
then basically return these query
results to a centralized reducer type
framework right so in terms of map and
reduce that map and reduce becomes a
test job essentially so you're
completely replacing the MapReduce
framework and tez is essentially
submitting the splits of those queries
across all these data nodes so the query
planner doesn't change it's just the
service which does that data access
point for you at the data locality
changes from MapReduce to teds that
answer a question a little bit
yes in a nutshell
right so if you so okay so the question
is why is why it takes so much time so
so today when you submit a query the
query planner basically goes to job
tracker and the jobtracker distribute
the word to all these task trackers
right in particular instance of that job
instantiate a JVM to do that job for you
right so there's a scheduling framework
that's built in causing that delayed
because the JVM has to start it's
roughly 30 seconds time now what if we
can eliminate that because we already
know the data locality where the data
exists and we can we can say hey if the
engine or JVM is already running we can
submit this job directly so we built
that query planner to understand what
tez is or test framework is and
eliminated MapReduce altogether that
means no more job tracker no more
scheduling through other resource
manager yarn says okay there's another
instance of this engine is running you
have all these resources go execute it
yes
that's a great question right so we
tested some of those concurrency
patterns so if you look sorry I disagree
so he's saying all these optimizations
are basically built on effective
research utilizations right so what if
you have multiple concurrent queries
what happens to the performance right so
this is not not by any means you're a
demon is running it has access to
everything right so it's a cop it's a
kind of see groups built onto it so if
you look at at a higher level framework
you have to use some sort of capacity
scheduler so when you pull all these
resources together and you say you mr.
customer a has a 20-percent execution or
twenty percent slice of the pie you're
not going to get many more task on top
of it so there is always the rest
resource scheduling is going to happen
from a higher level through capacity
schedule type of framework but you only
get a percentage of that particular
instance of resources happening on there
so effectively there will be concurrency
limits on on test service I don't know
the actual numbers for that yet to be
frank with you
at the moment yes so we haven't built
into any quotas today so that's still
available so the intermediate results
will be available as part of a steepness
yes but there is a there's one more zero
open so that you can build into a nice
DFS quotas available so that one crazy
developer cannot log onto everything so
you can actually set quotas moving
forward in HDFS there's a giro that will
eventually submit that includes the
total capacity intermediate ass capacity
and whole nine yards not there yet but
it will be there but let's answer your
question yes
you
so sure sorry okay so he's basically
asking that this is Ben this is
essentially turning into an MPP type of
a system and how will we manage how we
manage the resource scheduling when you
have large scale of Rights just example
1 and the second second I forgot sorry
like more concurrency right so MPP ok so
if you look at resource scheduler
perspective right so yarn will combine
capacity scheduler into it right so
today we have a capacity scheduler built
on top of it so you will always get a
percentage of the resources available to
you right in that that boils down to
disk memory CPU and it's not a mapping
map and reduce task anymore or slots
anymore it will portion of the instance
you can use it will be combined together
from yarn perspective so you will have
effectively out of the box anybody can a
hundred default group as hundred percent
utilization capacity so if you start two
thousand mapped or two thousand tasks
you'll be able to do whatever you want
to do with it but essentially the
resource scheduler will be a modified
capacity scheduler built on yarn that
will effectively manage that quarter
frame i should say quota the resources
better for you oh yes sir
you
so the question is what's a relationship
with new ha new high version and as it
used heads so high you mean hive 11
rights how high of 11 does not use test
hiya levin still uses MapReduce it's
still based on a map Hadoop 10 framework
the next version of high round September
time frame will use tez absolutely yes
right so I'll repeat the question no I
remember it'll be so when is when is it
available so in a nutshell so today you
have high of 11 available as full GA so
you can go ahead download high of 11
that does not come with tents okay you
can go to or converse or Apache web site
you can download test as alpha as well
as the new version of high with certain
of zeros made to it we can use test so
it is available on all four you have to
compile it and you know use it from that
perspective yes so in alpha are for well
high of 11 news so high of 11 as GA
product no but I've 11 combined with
some other jurors and tez isn't all for
you can get the real-time queering high
of 11 half and test just good yeah
that's another challenge so what we are
doing so that's that's one thing right
so go to apache was like okay i need to
download this particular project and 10
different patches with it to get to that
11 and half point so what we're doing as
Hortonworks we're basically combine
these and doing a quarterly release
cycle so we're essentially combined what
we what we have tested with from a
particular project and patches
perspective and putting that into a horn
or data platform again it's it's open
source product you can go ahead and
download from us or either from apache
but we're making sure that high of 11
with the 40 as I listed 3784 for star
schema joint is part of it tested and
works better but we're actually
releasing as a quarterly release cycle
right so Horner's data platform 1 2 3 10
4 which will coincide with 11 11 and a
half I think they learned and have water
please they pick up next time
yes sir
so yes there will be right the question
is it will there be support for TP
joints right so the answer is yes I
don't know if it made too high of 11 or
not so and it is it is it is on the road
map actually yes thank you thank you